[Music]
please welcome eric charles nielsen
ever since i graduated from college i've
been pursuing stand-up comedy with a
vengeance and not just because stand-up
comedy killed my father
i
actually suffer from a condition which
makes me practically unemployable
i majored in english
[Applause]
but you know what's terrible
everything
some comics file their jokes away in
folders i only own two folders one of
them is labeled plots to destroy the
world the other one is labeled teen
angst poetry
but it doesn't contain teen angst poetry
it contains
plots to destroy the world the one
labeled clusterus where the world
actually contains plots to take over the
world it's misdirection
another example of action is how you
think this is a joke about folders and
taking over the world it's actually a
joke about drag queens none of you were
expecting that
now i'm not a drag queen myself
but i'm concerned for them
i just want to say to them listen guys
you can't all be queens
do you know nothing of political science
if you want to be queens you have to
rule over somebody some kind of drag
peasants and from there to the lesser
ranks of their nobility drag baronesses
drag countesses drag duchesses one queen
per region
[Applause]
what they've got now is some kind of
drag anarchy
i've been suffering lately
from hallucinations
i saw a doctor
there was no doctor
so i have a human woman girlfriend
possibly due to a clerical error
but it's going well i i love her and i'm
especially happy before before i met her
i was not successful with girls
i have been on three dates in my entire
life
and that's counting a job interview they
included lunch
i'm happy
now i'd like to say a few words about
donkey kong
in the first donkey kong game donkey
kong this evil gorilla kidnapped a woman
and climbs to the top of a construction
site with her and you play as mario who
has to climb up after them and rescue
her
in the second donkey kong game donkey
kong jr
mario has kidnapped the gorilla and
taken him to the jungle and you play as
donkey kong's son who has to rescue his
father the two games cancel each other
out
if you play both of them you've done
nothing
then there is donkey kong country for
the super nintendo where donkey kong is
living on an island with a bunch of
other gorillas and they're being
threatened by evil crocodiles mario
isn't even there
do you know what this proves the people
at nintendo subscribe to jean jacques
rousseau's concept of the noble savage
you see donkey kong is innately good but
when he's exposed to the corrupting
influence of civilized society as
represented by the construction site he
goes berserk
also crocodiles are naturally evil also
i do not understand that song it's
raining men
because if we're really reigning men
they'd be crashing through roofs and
landing on pedestrians and splattering
into jelly all over the sidewalks and
yet the song is like hallelujah
it's raining men
[Applause]
[Music]
no
it is nonsense
don't applaud it
if you ask me
a better title for that song would be
it's raining yes
horrible
inescapable
death
[Applause]
in the form of men
[Applause]
eric charles nielsen everybody